bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7,8 week-end nous allons
revenir comme tous les vendredis sur les
moments forts de l'actualité culture
loisirs et sports et pendant 26 minutes
au cours de cette émission nous
parlerons idées de sorties avec les
fêtes de fin d'année avec la directrice
divine tourisme comme tous les 15 jours
sylvie léonard
mais tout d'abord direction les antilles
on ne dit pas chanter noël mais chanter
noël une tradition typiquement
antillaises où l'on se retrouve pour
chanter des cantiques de noël danser et
partager un repas commun
l'association culture et tradition
l'outre-mer n'a pas dérogé à la règle et
n'a pas manqué le rendez vous encore une
fois cette année
c'était samedi dernier salle gauguin à
montigny-le-bretonneux
à l'entrée on remet à chacun son livret
de quantic le chanter noël une tradition
antillaise qui perdu en métropole comme
ici à montigny par le biais de
l'association culture et tradition
d'outre-mer un bain de bonne humeur
entre chansons traditionnelles dans ses
plats typiques
c'est un moment de partage ces moments
de retrouvailles il ya également une
dame qui s'est vraiment y rappelle
également
de noël par rapport à la religion donc
les chansons à la fois
banier et chrétiens il ya des champs
spécifiques
yahiaoui des champions
ici comme par exemple le fameux petit
petit papa noël mais il y a des y'a des
couplets qu'on appelle des ritournelles
et ses ritournelles chanté en créole
donc il ya vraiment un mélange de
langues de change
et de huit
des chants des danses et un repas pris
en commun pour du fait maison autour de
la préparation du jambon des boudins du
pâté salé ou du fameux cochon aussi
préparé avec du riz et des pois d'angole
uniquement récoltés pendant la période
de décembre
ça replonge dans l'ambiance
des noëls traditionnels
comme mon pays ça rappelle des souvenirs
pertes voyager les gens de garder un peu
de cette culture renard et
voilà ça nous permet de faire connaître
et de faire connaître notre culture mais
je n'ai toujours faire de pétain tout
petit mes parents m'ont inculqué un peu
la culture antillaise mal de crâne ici
et ben moi je continue avec il est en
fait ce petit passeport qui vous donnez
vous
bon
oh
comme tous les quinze jours c'est la
chronique de sylvie leone à la
directrice divine tourisme bonjour
sylvie bonjour aujourd'hui vous nous
donner des idées de sorties pour les
fêtes de fin d'année et on va tout
d'abord découvrir quelques expositions
je crois moi là et ça va être beaucoup
moins exotique je vous préviens c'est
pas les antilles mais on est en ile de
france c'est quand même une île donc
c'est la bonne nouvelle
alors pour commencer je vous posez vous
proposer une exposition qui a lieu au
musée rend boli train est donc là on
peut y découvrir les circuits les
modèles réduits à vapeur vive mécanique
électrique dogmatique donc toutes sortes
de train pour les pour les passionnés il
y en a beaucoup
c'est au musée embolie train a rendez
vous pendant les vacances scolaires
on va partir aussi du côté du pecq cette
fois ci un peu tendance cirque je crois
voilà alors c'est encore autre chose
c'est une exposition de photos de cirque
qui se déroule au musée du pecq l'hôtel
de ville pardon du pec et sur cette expo
de photos on peut voir les clowns les
artistes les lions les trapézistes et
c'est traiter de manière assez ludique
donc on se retrouve au cirque eu 110 et
111 y est essai gratuite est encore une
bonne nouvelle pour les bricoleurs un
petit peu si j'ose dire on va aller voir
une exposition architecture et jeux de
construction du côté du musée du jouet
de poissy
alors c'est plus des ateliers qui sont
dédiés aux enfants qui sont on va se
fabriquer un monument
un château soi même avec des jeux de
construction les fameux légaux cap la
kinect est donc comme ça on pourra
concevoir soi-même son idéal de
construction et puis en même temps
découvrir les jeux de construction du 19
et 20ème siècle
évidemment fêtes de fin d'année rime
souvent avec patinoire plutôt éphémère
en général y en a encore quelques-unes
cette année dans les yvelines
alors il y en a il y en a dans deux
points des yvelines d'aidés importantes
on a une à versailles devant l'hôtel de
ville donc à deux pas du château et il y
en a une aussi donc place félix faure à
rambouillet donc il y en a une qui est
une patinoire écologique celle de
versailles et l'autre qui est une
patinoire de glace traditionnels
d'ailleurs celle de rambouillet nous
allons vous la faire découvrir tout à
l'heure dans un reportage ultérieure
quelques animations encore mais cette
fois ci contes et histoires dans les
châteaux yvelinois alors contes et
histoires c'est c'est une organisation
spécifiquement fait pour les fêtes de
fin d'année dans les monuments
historiques et dans notre département
c'est le château de maisons laffitte
c'est le château de rambouillet la la
villa savoye le corbusier donc qu'ils
vont organiser toutes ces animations
pour pour ces fêtes où on aura des
contes des ateliers des expositions
plein plein de choses spécifiquement
organisé à partir de contes pour les
enfants
alors peut-être le plus intrigant la
villa sonnantes à poissy de quoi
s'agit-il
alors la villa sonnantes à à poissy donc
encore à la villa savoye le corbusier
donc à partir de sons qui sont émis par
des matériaux de la villa savoye qui est
une villa de construction très moderne
les enfants vont imaginer des contes des
histoires et la villa sonnantes c'est le
bouquet final où on va avoir tout un tas
de bruit fait à partir des matériaux de
cette villa savoye très intéressant à
mon avis à découvrir on va partir du
côté des ateliers
du parc aux étoiles alors le parc aux
étoiles c'est à triel-sur-seine donc
dans le nord du département est en
principe le parc aux étoiles ne propose
des visites guidées que les mercredis et
les dimanches et là on peut pratiquer
des visites guidées tout
en tout les vacances et ses visites
guidées en fait vous permettre de
découvrir la biosphère les étoiles les
constellations de connaître deux
chariots du père noël de le voir
éventuellement et donc ça permet de
mieux connaître surtout pour les enfants
tout ce qui nous entoure et qui nous
fascine parce que c'est loin avis aux
passionnés d'astronomie notamment voilà
encore quelques animations je crois du
côté de saint germain en laye alors
c'est au musée maurice denis où il y a
les expositions tous au musée où là
c'est un peu spécial aussi pour noël on
a la possibilité d'avoir des ateliers
d'avoir des comptes
et puis on pourra aussi découvrir la
façon dont on travaille elena bis
puisque maurice denis auquel est dédié
ce musée est un abysse et donc on pourra
faire des ateliers de création en
fonction tout ça tout cela à découvrir
dans les semaines et jours qui viennent
merci beaucoup s'ils vivent pour cette
dernière chronique de l'année 2013 toute
la rédaction se joint à moi pour vous
fait évidemment de bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année puis on vous retrouve en 2014
pour la chronique idée de sortie merci
beaucoup merci vous en parliez
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure la patinoire à
rambouillet est installée jusqu'au 5
janvier prochain
une patinoire éphémère nom qui fait le
plaisir des petits mais aussi des grands
violaine thorez et jonathan vilma ne
l'ont découvert
sur cette patinoire installée à
rambouillet nolan accompagnée de sa
maman fait ses tout premiers pas sur la
glace ça fait du pape un gland avec 1500
d adam ya moi c'est super surtout qu'il
ya le la partie pour de petits où ils
sont un peu protégés sacha lui a préféré
laisser tomber les patins après
plusieurs chutes il s'est plutôt
résignés à regarder les copains je
tombais une quinzaine de femmes
c'est marrant mais à un moment où il
faut arrêter c'est ça fait mal mais
c'était marrant avec une vingtaine de
bénévoles jacques fait fonctionner cette
patinoire depuis maintenant six ans à
l'occasion des fêtes voit l'ami qu'est
ce que tu as pensé c'est sympa je suis
pas très stable mais en travaillant on
peut y arriver
bon en tout cas c'est comme nous voulait
venir ici à la patinoire de rambouillet
c'est tous les jours jusqu'au 5 janvier
jusqu'à 19 heures on s'y remet emilie
c'est parti
et vous avez aperçu en fin de sujet et
billy notre jeune stagiaire de troisième
qui était avec nous et toute la
rédaction cette semaine
c'est l'opération parvis en fête qui
s'est déroulée samedi dernier à magny
les hameaux différents stands étaient
proposés comme tous les ans sous le
regard bien intentionnés du père noël
et cela tombe bien car les enfants
avaient quelque chose à lui commander et
il est apparu comme une rockstar sur le
toit de la mairie de magny les hameaux
le père noël bien entendu les enfants
mamans des regards d'enfants totalement
émerveillé l'occasion de leur demander
ce qu'ils ont justement commandé au père
noël
comment dès lors avec un livre de l'état
des voitures télécommandées un chat avec
une maison des schtroumpfs des
animations tout au long de la journée
stands maquillage création de
décorations de noël et un spectacle tout
en poésie pour terminer ce parvis en
fait avec les allumeurs des toiles
et puis ce chiffre encore à retenir un
chiffre très important plus de 500 barbe
à papa ont été distribués ce samedi
consommer durable pendant les fêtes
c'est désormais possible
à brazzaville notamment à la ferme du
loup ravissant le foie gras est produit
de façon traditionnelle et en circuit
court
une méthode qui ce qui semble évidemment
de plus en plus apprécié les
consommateurs olivier maniscalco et
patrick jane le dixmude ont découvert ce
foie gras pascal lecoq et producteurs de
foie gras à bazens ville s'est produit
il les vend directement sur sa ferme
c'est ce qu'on appelle le circuit court
pas d'intermédiaire entre lui et ses
consommateurs et un rapport direct avec
ses clients pour expliquer ou faire
visiter son exploitation chez lui le
foie gras et traditionnelle les canards
sont nourris avec des céréales locales
et du maïs entier produits et séchez
directement dans sa ferme un mode de
fabrication qui permet un foie gras de
qualité et les clients apprécient les
gens aujourd'hui veulent savoir où ils
achètent ils ne veulent plus des
transports terminaux dans des conditions
plus ou moins douteuses et puis parfois
des produits dont on ne sait pas
réellement l'origine aujourd'hui ils
veulent savoir d'où ça vient
ils veulent que ce soit de la qualité
ils ont raison aujourd'hui on est même
approcher de plus en plus par la grande
distribution qui voudraient
qu'on produise un peu mais de toute
façon ce sera qu'un tout petit peu pour
eux parce qu'on peut pas n'a pas les
capacités de le faire et après on
dévalorise soir notre produit ici ont
faim je mettais à faire des comptes si
tu es trop importante la qualité de son
foie gras a cependant un coût
en moyenne ces produits sont de 30 à 50%
plus cher que dans une grande surface en
france d'après l'agencé de
l'environnement
les achats en circuits courts représenté
en 2010 environ 7% des achats
alimentaires depuis désormais 20 ans
yves live participe au développement
musical du département la sélection
d'artistes organisée par le centre de
ressources qui dit noah pour la musique
le cri accompagne et à accompagner
évidemment des dizaines d'artistes pour
célébrer cet anniversaire certains
groupes se sont reformés pour l'occasion
à moins de cent trente deux groupes et
six cent soixante musiciens ont été
accompagnés dans le développement de
leur carrière d'artiste et ce grâce au
dispositif
yves live créé par le centre de
ressources illinois pour la musique plus
communément appelé le cri yves live fête
cette année ses 20 ans bien entendu en
musique
c'est au café de la plage à maurepas que
se clôturent quatre jours de
célébrations un concert où le public a
pu assister hors formation
exceptionnelle de certains groupes
grand moment d'émotion en ampleur et en
toutes les soirées et stéréotypé
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que la
cour a moins joué le jeu de se reformer
pour l'occasion pour certains jusqu'à 15
ou 20 ans après et ça fait comme j'ai
tout à l'heure beaucoup d'émotion
beaucoup de travail pour eux finalement
et voilà quoi ça fait beaucoup de
souvenirs qui rejaillit dans ce soir
c'était là c'est presque une grande
famille public surtout dans l'invasion
puis c'est sympa de se dire qu'on
faisait de la musique à l'époque avec ce
groupe là et que des gens du coin
reviennent voir le groupe
ils n'ont pas oublié l'ambiance qu'il y
avait notre éclairage et ce qu'était la
bellec big dédicaces avec qui et voilà
qui étaient là ce soir aussi avec nous
qu'on avait déjà fait une réformation
con il ya deux ans j'apporte turbulences
et fait partie du réseau du cri
d'ailleurs on avait ce plaisir de se
revoir encore une fois toute façon de
toute façon du feu wes cates et que nous
on était des potes donc ça a été facile
parce que quand on s'est appelé pour
dire on joue ensemble forcément de
rejouer avec des potes on a vécu
vraiment des moments avec ce groupe là
donc ça a été facile après plus
difficile parce qu'il y en a qui habite
à toulouse à laval à brest ça c'était
plus difficile pour nous de la distance
des uns et des autres comme détiennent
une occasion de son fort mais on sera là
effectivement construit la dette ce
plaisir qui restent qui restera tout le
temps venu
on y touchera ya truc comme ça j'en ai
vues elles pourraient vous invite
vraiment bizarre
et puis non je suis toujours autant que
d'envoyer un peu chant la danse et on a
chanté il ya dix ans mais c'est rare
c'est pesant
comme chaque semaine nous vous faisons
découvrir le coup de coeur des cinémas
saint quentinois cette fois ci c'est
bertrand pigné le directeur du cinéma
les yeux d'elsa à saint cyr l'école qui
vous délivre son double coup de coeur
bonjour le coup de coeur cinéphiles set
cette semaine au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
sens hier l'école c'est une journée
spéciale noël une journée de cadeaux
cinématographique
le premier cadeau est à 16 heures c'est
un ciné conte que nous organisons
traditionnellement à noël ceci n'est
content
nous l'organisons avec la conteuse berti
soulier qui racontera quelques histoires
après qu'un goûter étaient proposés aux
enfants
et puis ensuite le film le kid de
charlie chaplin viendra clore la journée
cette journée c'est le 21 décembre
et ceci n'est content c'est à 16h et
c'est au tarif unique de 3 euros 50 pour
les petits les grands pour tout le monde
puisque c'est un film qui vous fera
venir et aussi peut-être un peu pleuré
mais qui provoquera beaucoup d'émotion
l'autre moment important de la journée
du samedi 21 décembre au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa c'est la projection du film
voyage au bout de l'enfer de deerhunter
de michael cimino à 21 à 20h15 pardon
20h15 le 21 décembre
ce film c'est un film mythique que tout
le monde a un peu vu je pense qu'en tout
cas moi j'en ai des souvenirs de ma
jeunesse
une histoire de soldats qui se
retrouvent au vietnam à devoir se jouer
à la roulette russe est forcé à jouer à
la roulette russe
c'est un film fort puissance
probablement un des meilleurs films qui
a été réalisé sur la guerre du vietnam
parce que parce que justement ce n'est
pas un film qui se passe uniquement sur
le territoire vietnamien
c'est l'avant et l'après guerre tout est
embrassé d'un seul coup c'est un film
qui en 79 quand il est sorti a eu un
succès public gigantesque 2 millions
d'entrées en france cinq oscars
christopher walken meilleur second rôle
meilleur montage meilleur fonds meilleur
réalisateur meilleur film
c'est un grand moment d'histoire du
cinéma d'histoire contemporaine
américaine aussi parce que c'est la
première fois que l'amérique regarde son
histoire son histoire guerrière dans les
yeux voilà avec un robert de niro
gigantesque en chasseur de serre mairie
ce type qui est magnifique
voilà qui virevoltent dans le film qui
une sorte d'ange comme ça et puis john
savage christopher walken enfin voilà
des gens dont vous avez probablement
entendu parler
un film que vous avez peut-être déjà vu
mais que vous n'avez probablement jamais
vu sur grand écran
en tout cas pas en version restaurée
numérique comme vous aurez l'occasion de
le voir le 21 décembre à 20h15 et
j'aurai l'honneur de vous le présenter
tout tantôt temps tours ottomanes audio
le reportage qui suit va certainement
rappeler des souvenirs à certains
d'entre vous en cette fin d'année le
fameux babar le roi et héros des
éléphants est à nouveau au coeur d'un
tout nouveau spectacle son histoire
racontée de manière originale est
proposée ce samedi à l'auditorium de la
batterie à guyancourt
une plongée dans l'univers des enfants
proposée par johan lavabre et toute son
équipe
yolaine thorez et patrick jacq de limoux
babar le roi des éléphants a aujourd'hui
92 ans mais pas une ride
son histoire était contée en musique ce
mercredi à guyancourt
hamza venue accompagnée de sa maman et
de sa petite soeur nous en fait le
résumé secteur de bab harkis qui a fait
les deux villes il a rencontré une dame
qui lui a offert un peu d'argent
merci mr n
après il a acheté des vêtements et il
est retourné dans son pays il est devenu
roi parce qu'il ya elle est à l'ancien
roi il était devenu il a annoncé manger
un championnat qu'ils ont du mal à
déléguer mortes durant le voyage céleste
et moi nous nous sommes fiancés
alors si je suis votre roi elle saura
votre rêve parmi les images qui défilent
tout au long du spectacle
on y trouve des dessins d'enfants ce
sont les oeuvres des jeunes du centre de
loisirs valadon et des élèves de l'école
robert desnos de guyancourt
moi le sens que je veux donner c'est
l'histoire de ce petit enfant qui est
orphelin qui perd sa maman et qui
néanmoins va va réussir à reconstruire
sa vie à devenir roi des éléphants
et alors lui qui avait eu une enfance si
malheureuse il a pour projet de rendre
les éléphants heureux et c'est ça que
j'ai voulu raconter avant de partir à
rambouillet elancourt ou encore
thionville l'équipe donnera encore trois
représentations ce samedi à l'auditorium
de la batterie tout le monde pense de
bon coeur
un peu plus
et pour terminer cette édition place au
sport comme d'habitude clairefontaine
accueillait le week-end dernier le women
paris soccer show l'occasion pour de
jeunes joueuses françaises les
yvelinoises de bon niveau sportif et
scolaire d'obtenir une bourse pour
évoluer au pays roi du football féminin
tout en poursuivant leurs études
universitaires jonathan littman pour les
images faustine évolue en division
d'honneur régionale avec montigny le
bretonneux
à 18 ans elle rêve du championnat de
soccer américain comme pour la
cinquantaine d'autres joueuses présentes
ce week-end à clairefontaine
cette détection et peut être sa
meilleure chance de venir fouler un jour
ce terrain avec l'équipe de france c'est
une bonne opportunité pour partir à
l'étranger déjà et puis les états unis
c'est un peu le pays du foot féminin
donc voilà c'est toujours bon à prendre
ce genre d'opportunité faut pas là il
faut pas la louper quoi sur la droite du
milieu de terrain camille quelque peu
stressé par la présence des recruteurs a
dû s'adapter aux exercices tactiques à
l'américaine c'est à peu près similaire
après c'est vrai que c'est vraiment au
niveau de l'intensité moi j'ai trouvé un
changement où ils nous en demande
beaucoup plus et enfin faut vraiment on
sai a pratiquement aucune pause enfin
deux entre les nids les exercices comme
il demande beaucoup de physique
d'intensité et tout est ce que en france
on a beaucoup moins apparemment et c'est
vrai que c'est fatigant mais ça va ça ça
tient pour attirer les meilleurs
éléments du week-end la plupart des
universités sont prêtes à prendre en
charge la majorité de leur cursus en
moyenne 200 mille euros sur quatre ans
et la vingtaine de recruteurs présents
au bord du terrain semble avoir repéré
quelques talents a brief cincinnati j'ai
pu voir des joueuses techniquement très
intéressante et certaines possèdent
également des qualités athlétiques et un
jeu plus rapide qui leur permettrait
d'avoir un beau parcours dans notre
programme universitaire malgré des
actions intéressantes lors de
l'opposition et un but marqué par
faustine les deux joueuses
saint-quentinoise n'ont pas obtenu
d'entretiens individuels pour espérer
continuer l'aventuré outre atlantique
et pour terminer ce set week-end
évidemment l'agenda de vos fêtes de fin
d'année cette fois-ci tout d'abord le 21
décembre on en parlait dans le coup de
coeur du cinéphile
le cinéma les yeux d'elsa
saint-cyr-l'ecole fête noël ce samedi
dès 16 heures vous pourrez vous rendre
en famille pour un goûter suivi d'une
séance compter avec la projection du
film le kid de charlie chaplin à 20h15
pour les plus grands une séance
exceptionnelle d'un autre classique
voyage au bout de l'enfer de michael
cimino tarifs à 3 euros 50 sur
réservation ou en prévente et du 26
décembre au 31 décembre la dame noire le
club d'échecs de montigny le bretonneux
organise son 16e tournoi de noël
vous pourrez admirer évidemment cette
ronde avec les meilleurs joueurs de la
région
pour ma part c'est la fin de ce week end
ce 7,8 week-end pardon pour ma part je
vous retrouverai pour un tout dernier
7,8 sport en 2013 avec une page spéciale
consacrée aux premiers essais de la
piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines par les
équipes de france d'ici là excellent
week-end sur tv